[Musique]
le département organise des entretiens
dans le cadre de sa campagne de
recrutement 2020 d'ouvriers foresti des
ouvriers qui seront recrutés en pec
parcours emploi compétences pour pouvoir
prétendre à ces entretiens il faut être
bénéficiaires du rsa
puisque c'est la condition nécessaire
pour que la personne puisse être truqué
sur les grecs qui font l'objet de la
présente campagne
c'est le public cible qui commet qui est
privilégiée par le département ce sont
les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi qui sont donc le public
spécifiquement ciblée sur les contrats
aidés
ces personnes seront mis à l'encadrement
de l'om f dans le cadre de leur contrat
peck pour effectuer tous les travaux
liés aux postes d'ouvriers forestiers
des entretiens répartis sur plusieurs
jours aux quatre coins de l'île près de
230 candidats sont alors l'entretien
dure environ une dizaine de minutes
donc c'est une prise de contact avec
l'agent don
- d'un crime donc si sa motivation pour
le poste donc décrit dans l'est
défections d'ouvriers forestier on va
leur expliquer la difficulté de travail
à la fois sur l'entretien des sentiers
d'entretien du site et tout ce qui est
multi espèces invasives qu'on a on
recourait à l'arrêt serait la condition
les conditions physiques sont sont très
importantes et miranda des candidats qui
sont quand même motivé qui connaissent
déjà bien le wan hé oui on a eu des bons
candidats se battent à pinces à la fin
de ces entretiens 76 personnes seront
recrutées comme ouvrier forestier
[Musique]